when you're in the line it could be
risky to get out even for good reason we
went to the bathroom and the line grew
about three times cues like these have
been uncommon at canada's busiest
airport during most of the pandemic but
many canadians have the travel bug again
we are going to atlanta my daughter is
getting married this family hasn't
traveled anywhere in three years the
pandemic sought of that we couldn't do
nothing with pandemic right so
there was not much we could plan
it was just
driving in the city this is expected to
be the busiest travel day at pearson
airport since the pandemic began about
85 000 travelers leaving and returning
those who haven't been for a trip in a
while may not know the rules not
everyone can go into the airport you
either got to be an employee or you're a
passenger traveling that day if you are
traveling don't make assumptions and
come equipped have all their documents
ready because if you're traveling to
another country they could have their
own requirements so make sure to do your
research
tests could be required and one concern
we heard that travelers will assume that
masks aren't required in airports later
this month wrong it's a positive step
that the mass mandate is changing but we
do want people to know that mass will
still be required inside the airports as
we're federally regulated many of those
traveling aren't packing light and
they've brought a sense of humor lots of
bikinis
yeah no no just tons of stuff back in
the line this family is trying to escape
some overwhelming news that's very
personal it's been difficult we're
ukrainian so we've been focusing very
much on the war the effort continues but
we need to also be parents
get some rest focus on the kids
so the porters are busy you can see how
many people have got large suitcases
there's a dog inside the cage over here
and if you didn't know that there has
been a pandemic for the last couple of
years and you just dropped in to pearson
airport you wouldn't know it because as
i said thousands of people here today it
seems to be a march break like a typical
march break of course it isn't uh three
years ago we had this many people as we
did today
the pandemic is not over but for
travelers who are heading out for spring
break for march break this year it sure
feels like it